l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement
et la première d'entre elles va être
posée par la présidente pano pour le
groupe la France insoumise
présidente madame la Première ministre
vous aiderez
vous céderez car vous ne tenez qu'à neuf
voix
vous céderez car de Français sur trois
souhaitent votre départ vous céderez car
passer en force contre le peuple les
syndicats le Parlement relève d'une
folie vous céderez car le risque d'un
débordement de colère est déjà trop
grand vous céderez car la police seule
ne parviendra pas à faire régner l'ordre
vous céderez car un caprice du président
ne mérite pas de menacer la paix civile
du pays vous céderez car votre réforme
des retraites relève d'un choix
politique et qu'il est possible d'en
faire un tout autre vous céderez car au
fond vous en lisez le pays dans une
crise de régime inutile
vous céderez car nous serons nombreux
jeudi pour la censure populaire et
toujours plus nombreux encore
vous céderez car la dignité des gens n'a
pas de prix oui vous céderez car il n'y
aura pas de retour à la normale possible
sans céder vous céderez mais alors
qu'est-ce que vous laisserez vous
céderez mais vous aurez abîmé comme
rarement la parole politique
instrumentaliser la Constitution à des
fins autoritaires dévoyé comme jamais la
démocratie parlementaire confondue avec
une roulette russe quand ce n'est pas un
jeu de pile ou face
bafoué la démocratie sociale en traitant
les syndicats comme des figurants
attaquer le droit de grève et de
manifestations à coups de réquisition et
de répression fait honte à la France à
l'international
vous céderez et au moment où vous
céderez il sera déjà trop tard car votre
de votre pouvoir il ne restera que des
débris madame la Première ministre un
peu de courage il ne reste pas Emmanuel
Macron plus beaucoup d'options retrait
du texte ou retour devant le peuple
combien de temps encore le président de
la République va-t-il nous faire perdre
du temps avant de céder
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente
ont un sens
autoritarisme c'est le mot que vous
employez pour parler de notre
Constitution
illégitime
illégitime c'est le mot que vous
utilisez pour décrire le Parlement le
débat les institutions
assassins c'est l'insulte qui a hurlé
l'un de vos députés en attaquant le
ministre du Travail
dégoût fureur ce sont vos paroles hier
dans un registre haineux qui est
désormais votre habitude s'il vous plaît
censure populaire ce sont les mots de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelant au
soulèvement face au Parlement
madame la Présidente panneau hier soir
votre violence verbale à déborder dans
la rue mais alors là sans surprise
prise vous n'avez plus de mots pour
condamner les violences
au contraire vous continuez sans roulage
votre attaque systématique des
institutions républicaines vous vous en
prenez aux policiers et aux gendarmes
vous remettez en cause leur travail leur
comportement doit être exemplaire et ils
le savent tous tout signalement et
systématiquement examiner pour ma part
je veux le rendre hommage il nous
protège il protège nos institutions et
l'ordre républicain
je veux dire notre solidarité aux 400
policiers et gendarmes blessés ces
derniers jours dont 42 cette nuit je
veux saluer enfin nos sapeurs-pompiers
qui ont été fortement mobilisés alors
madame la Présidente panot moi aussi
j'ai quelques mots à partager que vos
dernières interventions et l'attitude de
votre groupe ces dernières semaines
m'ont rappelé
le premier le premier c'est duplicité
c'est vous entendre vous plaindre de ne
pas avoir pu aller jusqu'au bout du
texte que vous avez tout fait pour
bloquer
anti-parlementarisme c'est toute votre
ligne politique à force de tenter de
couvrir la voie de toute parole
contradictoires à force d'opposer la
légitimité de la rue au Parlement
intimidation ce sont les actes que vous
justifiez en minimisant les dégradations
et les menaces à l'encontre des
parlementaires ces dernières semaines
madame la Présidente panot avec votre
groupe vous êtes des représentants de la
nation alors respectez le résultat des
urnes et les votes au Parlement
respecter nos institutions et respecter
enfin notre démocratie
je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick noeuder pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la Présidente ma question
concerne monsieur le ministre de la
Santé je voudrais évoquer deux sujets
qui sont importants pour la santé de nos
concitoyens le premier celui de la prise
en charge des accidents vasculaires
cérébraux 150 000 patients par an en
sont victimes un Français sur 5 en sera
en forain durant sa vie sur les 577
députés que nous sommes je vous laisse
calculer 115 en seront victimes le 24
février monsieur le ministre par Arrêté
vous avez des remboursé la sonde qui
permet d'extraire le caillot et par-delà
une prise en charge rapide pour éviter
les séquelles et le handicap le deuxième
sujet concerne la prise en charge des
chimiothérapies où là encore vous avez
décidé de dérembourser les molécules de
chimiothérapie exercée en hôpitaux de
jour sous réserve qu'elles représentent
30% du forfait cela représente 450 000
patients par an sur les 4 millions de
nos concitoyens qui sont atteints
malheureusement d'un cancer donc je
voudrais mettre fin à cette insincérité
et cette hypocrisie je suis fier de
porter aujourd'hui la jonquille témoigne
de la recherche pour le cancer mais en
même temps je trouve scandaleux qu'on
fasse choisir à nos centres de
cancérologie de faire des
chimiothérapies ou de payer la note de
chauffage
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
une odeur il n'y a ni hypocrisie ni
sincérité je vous rassure tout de suite
vous parlez de médicaments et
dispositifs médicaux qui ont été mis
dans ce que l'on appelle la liste en
Suisse cette liste en Suisse elle est
destinée aux médicaments et aux
dispositifs médicaux innovants et
onéreux cela permet de les financer de
façon dérogatoire en plus du financement
du séjour hospitalier puisque leur coût
ne permet pas d'être intégré dans le
séjour hospitalier cette liste en Suisse
est des dynamiques il y a des
médicaments des dispositifs qui entrent
qui en sortent lorsqu'ils en sortent de
plus de pas du tout dire qu'ils ne sont
pas remboursés ça veut simplement dire
qu'ils sont pris en charge dans le cou
du séjour hospitalier en ce qui concerne
les produits dont vous parlez au 1er
mars effectivement après deux ans de
discussion avec les industriels
concernés des anticancéreux des
antifongiques ont été supprimés de cette
liste parce qu'ils étaient suffisamment
anciens pour réintégrer le mode de
financement habituel c'est la même chose
pour le cathéter de thrombo-aspiration
dont vous parlez qui permet en montant
par voie artérielle soit de faire une
artériographie cérébrale soit d'aspirer
le caillot responsable lui aussi est
toujours disponible dans les
établissements de santé et il a intégré
dans le financement global maintenant du
séjour hospitalier c'est quelque chose
qui est habituel qui est récurrent il y
a une cagnotte entre guillemets
financière mise de côté pour aider les
établissements qui dans la période de
transition n'arriverait pas à faire face
à cette dépense mais en aucun cas cela
veut dire que ces produits ne sont plus
utilisés ne sont plus remboursés ou sera
inefficace je le redise sont toujours
pris en charge dans le cadre du forfait
hospitalier et ils sont bien entendu
efficaces je vous remercie
le ministre monsieur noder monsieur le
ministre vous explications ne sont
malheureusement pas là pour rassurer les
patients et surtout les médecins les
sociétés savantes ces préconisations que
vous faites sont contre les
recommandations de la Haute Autorité de
Santé et je crois qu'à l'heure où nous
sommes il est pas du tout le moment de
supprimer le remboursement des
chimiothérapies et des guides
d'aspiration pour limiter l'impact des
accidents vasculaires cérébraux vous ne
pourrez pas vous en tirer comme ça par
une pirouette je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est au président Marc
Angeli pour le groupe horizon merci
madame le Président
la première ministre notre pays traverse
actuellement une période troublée un
constat s'impose à tous celui d'une vie
d'inquiétude de nos concitoyens quant à
leur avenir et qui pourrait leur donner
tort les sujets de préoccupation ne
manquent pas désormais à l'inflation se
rajoute le spectre d'une potentielle
Chris bancaire la guerre en Ukraine sans
Lise et l'actualité récente nous a
encore rappelé l'empireuse nécessité de
faire tout notre possible pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique il en
va de notre présent mais aussi de celui
des générations futures la conséquence
c'est un contexte de tension et
notamment de tension sociale je ne
n'irai pas que la désapprobation que
suscite le projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
adoptée hier joue un rôle dans leur mise
à jour mais il ne faudrait pas prétendre
qu'il ne s'agit que de cela c'est
d'autre chose qui est en train de se
jouer dans la société française il
s'agit d'une appétence légitime pour la
correction des injustices sociales est
territorial je pense par exemple aux
enjeux majeurs posés par l'accès aux
soins ou encore au service public c'est
donc dans ce climat que l'attention
sociale se pose cette question c'est
celle de notre rapport à la valeur
travail et du sens qu'on lui donne le
groupe Horizon est apparenté en est
convaincu le travail amène à la
prospérité et la prospérité garantit
l'élévation du niveau de vie de chacun
nous pensons notamment que la question
du partage de l'effort de la
redistribution des résultats de l'effort
productif doit être plus que jamais posé
sur la table madame la Première ministre
personne de doute ici dans mon groupe de
votre engagement pour fixer un cap clair
même d'apaiser le pays et de rassurer
les Français aussi pouvez-vous dire à la
représentation nationale quelles seront
les grands axes de travail du
gouvernement dans les prochains mois
pour contribuer à réduire les injustices
et plus généralement ce sentiment
d'injustice je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le Président la parole
est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Laurent marchandelli hier
après 175 heures de débat la réforme des
retraites fruits d'un compromis entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
fruit du travail de tous les
parlementaires qui voulaient garantir
l'avenir de nos retraites a été adopté
je veux saluer à nouveau le travail des
parlementaires de la majorité qui ont
permis d'améliorer ce texte et on fait
blocs à chaque étape monsieur le
Président Laurent marquant jelly je sais
notamment le travail et l'implication de
votre groupe qui apportait des
propositions pour ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt pour la prise en compte
la prise en compte des trimestres de
travaux d'utilité collectif pour la
retraite ou encore pour que notre
système ne rajoute pas de l'injustice à
la douleur de la perte d'un jeune enfant
je veux également profiter de ce moment
pour saluer à nouveau les parlementaires
hors de la majorité qui ont participé à
bâtir ce compromis ils ont été fidèles
au principe de leur famille politique et
fidèle à la demande des Français de nous
voir travailler ensemble au-delà des
postures et des intérêts personnels
monsieur le Président Laurent Marc
Angeli cette réforme est nécessaire mais
comme vous l'avez souligné elle soulève
des inquiétudes et des interrogations
chez nos concitoyens elle renvoie à des
questions plus larges sur notre rapport
au travail l'évolution des carrières sur
la manière de répartir justement les
forts mon objectif mon objectif celui de
mon gouvernement avec la majorité c'est
de répondre à ces interrogations c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons notamment que
l'accord sur le partage de la valeur
trouvée entre les partenaires sociaux
soient retranscrit rapidement dans la
loi c'est pourquoi nous continuerons
dans les prochains mois à chercher les
meilleures réponses au préoccupations
des Français mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour pour y parvenir nous ne
renoncerons jamais à chercher des
compromis et à travailler au plus tôt
avec les parlementaires
pour y parvenir nous voulons plus que
jamais prendre appui sur la démocratie
sociale notamment en retranscrivant les
accords trouvés par les organisations
syndicales et patronales pour y parvenir
nous devons continuer à nous appuyer sur
les territoires et Associés davantage
nos concitoyens à la prise de décision
monsieur le Président Laurent Marc
Angeli je sais que je peux compter sur
la majorité pour nous aider à mener ce
travail et je veux compter au-delà des
clivages sur tous les députés qui
veulent agir pour notre pays et trouver
des solutions au service des Français je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Chenu
pour le rassemblement national
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la première
ministre madame la Première ministre
nous savons désormais les Français avec
nous que nous n'avons plus rien
n'attendre du président de la République
ni sincérité ni respect ni écoute des
Français ni considération du Parlement
vous avez acté hier comme une gifle
supplémentaire avec ce 49-3 l'ampleur du
mépris que vous portez à la France aux
français et à leurs attentes c'est
évidemment la fin d'une certaine idée de
la démocratie parlementaire mais c'est
surtout la négation du peuple français
la négation de la volonté populaire hier
sans aucun doute sans aucune once de
doute vous avez prouvé que le pouvoir
aujourd'hui dans notre pays les
représenté par un homme par une seule
idée par une seule idéologie vous avez
ensuite avec sinisme ces îles conseils
constitutionnel comme si vous étiez vous
le gouvernement la partie la plus lésée
dans cette affaire alors que ce sont les
Français qui sont les
indignés cette Assemblée nationale ne
sont dupe de rien vous ne gouvernez plus
vous imposer contente de vous-même vous
revendiquez même la victoire votre loi
n'a aucune légitimité politique vous
avez tout raté là-dedans la bataille de
l'opinion politique les concertations
inexistantes le passage devant
l'Assemblée nationale même un deal vers
eux avec une fausse opposition en
échange de quelques sorties d'autoroute
madame la Première ministre la question
est simple qu'attendez-vous pour rendre
qu'attendez-vous pour rendre le meilleur
service que vous pouvez rendre à notre
République c'est à dire de démissionner
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Chenu de quoi
parlez-vous
de quoi parlez-vous lorsque vous
remettez en cause la légitimité du texte
qui a été adopté hier par le Parlement
ce texte est allé au bout de son
cheminement démocratique ce texte c'est
un engagement du Président de la
République pris pendant la campagne
c'est un engagement pris par l'ensemble
des candidats de la majorité
présidentielle qui l'ont présenté
assumer devant les Français c'est un
texte qui a fait l'objet de quatre mois
de concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux quatre mois qui ont permis de
l'enrichir et le texte qui a été adopté
n'est pas le texte du Gouvernement c'est
un texte qui a été amélioré amélioré par
le travail du Parlement et amélioré par
les concertations c'est un texte qui a
connu 175 heures de débat qui n'a pas pu
aller au bout de son examen ici à cause
de l'obstruction mais qui a été adopté
par le Sénat dans son intégralité avant
d'être adopté en commission mixte
paritaire ce texte monsieur le député va
permettre des avancer des avancées dès
le 1er septembre allez vous dire non
allez vous dire non à la revalorisation
des petites retraites allez vous dire
non à la meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité allez vous dire non à
l'emploi des seniors monsieur le député
vous interrogez la première ministre en
lui disant qu'elle devrait arrêter mais
au contraire nous allons continuer dans
l'intérêt des Français je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur et
c'est le ministre vous avez empêché avec
même la première ministre le vote parce
que vous alliez le perdre vous alliez
perdre ce vote devant la présentation
nationale alors Monsieur le Ministre
rendez-vous
utile accompagné madame borne vers la
sortie
[Applaudissements]
il y a une chose qui est sûre dans ce
que vous avez dit c'est peut-être la
seule chose devrait ça n'est pas vous
qui a d'empêcher le débat puisque vous
avez été muet pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez été muet parce que votre projet il
coûte 26 milliards d'euros qu'il aurait
ruiné les Français et ruiner les petits
retraités
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur Éric Bothorel
pour le comprenez sans
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
c'est de cette question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères
700 jours hier Olivier Dubois est libre
700 jours loin des siens
700 jours loin des siens et ce matin les
doutes les questions c'est de leur place
à la joie de retrouver pour sa famille
ses amis ses collègues pour Deborah Marc
David pierre et pardon de ne pas citer
les 124 membres de la bouteille de la
métropole aux Antilles en passant par le
Mali de retrouver celui qui leur a tant
manqué celui pour lequel ils n'ont rien
épargné de leurs efforts pour qu'ils
sachent ou qu'il ait pu être que nous ne
l'oublions pas porter un bracelet au
poignet parlez lui à la radio dans la
presse sur les festivals comme à Paimpol
par exemple égrainer les jours comme sur
le compte Twitter Jean-Marc Laffont et
tant d'autres le nom d'Olivier Dubois a
toujours été grâce à eux plus qu'un
murmure qui s'éteint dans la nuit
profonde d'un désert propice parfois
l'oubli
la France n'abandonne pas les siens
jamais ou qu'ils soient au-delà de la
joie que nous partageons de revoir
Olivier se pose une question bien plus
pragmatique quand percevra-t-il son
indemnisation le fond garantit des
victimes dont nous disposons en France
est un dispositif formidable que
d'autres pays nous envient et nous avons
beaucoup de raisons de nous en féliciter
toutefois il demeur marquer par
plusieurs défauts dont les victimes nous
alerte régulièrement lenteur
insupportable sentiment de devoir
justifier pendant des années la violence
subie et ses conséquences face à un
organisme à qui l'on impose aucun délai
de traitement pour mémoire certains
otages capturés il y a 10 ans non par
exemple toujours pas reçu leur offre
définitive tout comme des victimes du 13
novembre le fond réclamant toujours plus
de pièces l'argent oui ne guérit pas les
stigmates du terrorisme mais il aide à
donner les moyens aux victimes
d'envisager l'avenir et la
reconstruction madame la ministre
comment peut-on donc améliorer ce
processus indemnitaire et assurer la
pérennité de ce fond aujourd'hui des
visiteurs je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
botterel
Olivier Dubois est de retour enfin
il était aux tâches d'un groupe
djihadiste depuis le 8 avril 2021 et
depuis le 1er jour sa libération était
une priorité de la France elle a été
pleinement mobilisée dans cet objectif
désormais atteint vous le savez monsieur
le député nous devons souvent agir avec
discrétion tout en tenant les familles
informées autant que nous le pouvons et
je sais que notre discrétion parfois
n'est pas comprise elle est pourtant la
condition de l'efficacité alors
aujourd'hui comme votre assemblée hier
et comme aujourd'hui encore je ressens
soulagement et joie émotion aussi bien
sûr et je veux m'associer au bonheur
d'Olivier au bonheur de sa famille de
ses proches de ses enfants en
particulier et au bonheur de sa
profession car je voudrais rappeler que
nous avons besoin d'une presse libre
indépendante et de qualité pour assurer
notre démocratie
je remercie aussi à nouveau les
autorités du Niger de leur aide qui a
été déterminante monsieur le député
Olivier Dubois continuera de bénéficier
du soutien de l'État le président de la
République l'a rappelé le 11 mars lors
de la cérémonie dommage aux victimes du
terrorisme aux Invalides nous sommes au
côté pour toujours des victimes du
terrorisme à ce jour le fond de garantie
a pu indemniser
95%, 95% des victimes des attentats de
2015 et 2016 et verset près de 300
millions d'euros alors oui cela
nécessite souvent des expertises
médicales précises des experditions
scientifiques et des délais et pour
autant notre système est souvent pris en
modèle en Europe et je terminerai en
rappelant que si de nos compatriotes
sont encore retenues aujourd'hui
arbitrairement en Iran alors pensons
aussi et sachez que nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés pour obtenir leur
libération je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Fabien Roussel
pour le groupe GDR
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre c'est avec une extrême gravité
que je m'adresse à vous alors même que
le pays vous signifie que votre coup de
force sur la retraite à 64 ans et non
seulement inadmissible mais dangereux
quand le peuple rejette aussi
massivement votre réforme quand toutes
les organisations syndicales font front
communs quand le Parlement est piétiné
c'est la France et c'est la République
que vous abîmez non seulement vous
plongez le pays dans une crise profonde
mais en plus vous faites le choix d'user
de la matraque de la répression
syndicale et des réquisitions pour faire
taire maintenant la contestation je vous
le dis solennellement madame la Première
ministre
face au chaos que vous provoquez par vos
choix nous ne répondrons pas par le
chaos nous appelons respect du peuple de
la démocratie sociale au respect des
organisations syndicales avec qui vous
ne dialoguez plus depuis le 10 janvier
et nous appelons aussi au respect du
Parlement
160 députés issus de 5 groupes ont
déposé cet après-midi un recours au
Conseil constitutionnel
255 parlementaires
issus de 9 groupes du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale ont aussi des
pesées une demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée inscrit dans notre
Constitution allez vous dire aussi que
cette démarche serait-il légitime rien
que ces recours doivent vous conduire à
ne pas promulguer la loi
respectez-les
respectez-nous respectez ces millions de
salariés encore en grève pacifiquement
et qui manifesteront ce jeudi 23 et j'en
profite pour appeler les Français à
faire de cette journée la plus puissante
des mob ilisations de notre pays madame
la Première ministre
rendez les armes nous voulons la paix la
paix civile retirez votre réforme des
retraites les Français ont besoin de
retrouver la confiance dans leur
démocratie dans leur République je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député Roussel
avant de revenir sur la réforme des
retraites je tiens à vous signaler ou à
vous dire pardonnez-moi deux choses on
est quoi votre question la première vous
avez utilisé une expression vous avez
utilisé une expression la répression par
la matraque
c'est une expression que je ne peux
accepter que le gouvernement n'accepte
pas et cette expression monsieur le
député me permet de dire le soutien de
tout le gouvernement aux forces de
police qui assure l'ordre qui ramène
l'ordre dans les rues de Paris comme
dans les rues des autres villes qui se
l'autorité du ministre de l'Intérieur
protège les bâtiments publics protège
les élus et leur travail doit être
saluer monsieur le député leur travail
doit être saluer parce que le maintien
de l'ordre c'est aussi le maintien de la
liberté et le maintien de la capacité
d'expression libre de chacun la deuxième
chose Monsieur le Député que je ne peux
partager c'est lorsque vous dites que le
Parlement a été piétiné comment dire que
le Parlement était piétiné alors qu'il a
eu 175 heures de débats que le seul
moment où le Parlement n'a pas pu
délibérer c'est lorsque les groupes de
gauche de cette assemblée organisé une
obstruction systématique pour empêcher
l'Assemblée nationale de délibérer et
privé les députés de ce qui fait
l'essence de leur fonction c'est-à-dire
voter et ainsi homme enfin Monsieur le
Député vous nous appelez à la
responsabilité la responsabilité c'est
de mener la réforme et de la monnaie
maintenant il y a un déficit vous le
savez et
une pause attendre reportée lorsqu'on
met une réforme en pause le déficit
n’est pas en pause il continue à se
creuser et les marches les enjeux c'est
encore plus difficile à relever être
responsable c'est garantir l'avenir du
système par répartition et de l'avenir
d'un système de solidarité c'est ce que
nous faisons et c'est l'enjeu et
l'honneur de cette majorité que de
conduire cette réforme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Géraldine Bannier
pour le groupe démocrate
la question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre le baccalauréat
porte d'entrée du supérieur avec la
charge symbolique qu'il revêt les émois
qu'il suscite pour des jeunes qui
passent là leur premier véritable examen
est au cœur de l'actualité de fait les
épreuves de spécialité du baccalauréat
tel que prévu par la dernière réforme
ont commencé hier
elle compte pour près d'un tiers de la
note finale et pour la première fois se
déroule enfin selon le calendrier prévu
bousculé par la covid ces deux dernières
années
le contexte social lié à la réforme des
retraites inquiète dans la mesure où des
blocages d'établissement ou des grèves
de surveillance peuvent venir perturber
les épreuves on imagine sans difficulté
l'angoisse des lycéens qui préparent ces
épreuves et la position délicate des
professeurs forcément tous très attachés
à la réussite de leurs élèves quel que
soit leur choix je voudrais d'ailleurs
vous dire combien les assurés de notre
soutien et toujours nécessaire et plus
que jamais indispensable la profession
fait face à dimanche difficultés dans sa
tâche quotidienne dans une société en
voie d'archipalisation et où l'autorité
est trop souvent remise en question
votre ministère a indiqué que des
surveillants supplémentaires ont été
convoquées et il ne semblait pas exclu
qu'on puisse recourir au préfet en cas
de difficultés pour accéder au centre
d'examen pouvez-vous nous faire un point
de situation combien d'élèves n'ont pas
pu passer leurs épreuves quelle
possibilité pour eux de le faire quelle
vigilance aussi pour la phase de
correction merci de votre éclairage
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à Monsieur papenza et
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Bannier vous l'avez dit
l'organisation du baccalauréat se
déroule dans des conditions normales
prévues par la réforme après les
difficultés que nous avons conduites en
raison de la crise sanitaire ces deux
dernières années c'est une grosse
machine
536000 candidats 2600 centre d'examens
et 35000 correcteurs et les épreuves de
spécialité à ce jour se déroule tout à
fait normalement il n'y a pas eu de
difficultés hier il y en a pas la
connaissance aujourd'hui à l'exception
d'une fuite pour ceux qui concernent la
série STMG qui nécessite d'imprimer des
sujets de secours cet après-midi et nous
n'attendons pas de difficultés
particulières demain vous l'avez dit
nous avons prévu des surveillants en
surnuméraire qui ont été mobilisés Sylla
hier et aujourd'hui nous avons également
veillé à ce que les blocages n'empêchent
pas les candidats d'entrer dans les
centres d'examen aucun candidat n'a été
empêché d'entrer dans un centre d'examen
et nous allons suivre après la
numérisation de toutes les copines nous
allons suivre la progression des
corrections jusqu'au 11 avril donc
jusqu'à présent les conditions se
déroulent tout à fait normalement et je
tiens à saluer d'ailleurs la
responsabilité de celles et ceux qui ont
appelé à ce que les épreuves de
spécialités se déroulent normalement
nous ferons un bilan après la session du
baccalauréat notamment du point de vue
des programmes pour envisager ce qu'il
peut ce qui peut être aménagé mais à ce
stade nous n'avons pas de crainte quant
à l'organisation générale de la session
2023 du baccalauréat
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame Banier merci monsieur
Philippe très bonne chance à l'ensemble
des 536 000 candidats
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Andy kerbra
pour le groupe la France insoumise
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur je
cite une victime faut que je fouille
dans ta culotte tes sale ça me dégoûte
tu sens mauvais je vais te fouiller dans
la chatte qui a bien pu dire ça en
glissant la main dans les parties
génitales d'une jeune étudiante des
prédateurs sexuels des criminels il
s'agit de policier lors d'une fouille au
corps mardi dernier dans ma
circonscription
quatre jeunes femmes ont porté plainte
une enquête de l'IGPN est ouverte ma
première question est simple monsieur le
ministre rendez-vous hommage à ses
agents ou sanctionner vous c'est
pratique et allez-vous les surprendre
les agents pendant la durée de l'enquête
il s'agit de votre responsabilité
monsieur le ministre
alors que vous portiez garant de la
liberté manifestée depuis l'application
du 49-3 sur votre impopulaire réforme
des retraites vos consignes organisent
la brutalité policière comme avec les
gilets jaunes partout en France les
faits sont accablants déplacements en
garde à vue sans motif se multiplient
que jeudi soir 292 interpellations 283
ont été classés sans suite hier 300
interpellations combien de jours encore
continuerez-vous à organiser la
détention arbitraire de notre pays
dans un moment du contestation politique
et sociale largement soutenue votre
réponse c'est le nassage le matraquage
les bombes de désencerclement et les
tirs tendus vos méthodes violences vise
à faire peur aux Français la politique
de la terreur de la privation de liberté
se déploie à marche forcée vous ne
pourrez pas en bastiller tous les
opposants à votre réforme
la Ligue des droits de l'Homme vous
condamne le syndicat de l'administrature
vous condamne le Syndicat des Avocats de
France vous condamne le rapporteur
spécial des Nations Unies vous condamne
le désordre ce n'est pas les
manifestations ce ne sont pas les grèves
le désordre c'est vous avec votre éparme
avec vos réquisitions et votre brutalité
policière monsieur le ministre vous qui
est le donneur d'ordre assumez votre
responsabilité dans l'escalade de la
violence sachez que nous nous céderons
pas et serons mobilisés jusqu'au retrait
de votre réforme
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
comme vous je voudrais avoir un mot pour
ces 394 policiers et gendarmes blessés
et
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie d'avoir
je vous remercie d'avoir souligné leur
courage et une pensée toute particulière
pour ce CRS qui ce matin est fracture
ouverte de la malléole et qui au moment
où nous parlons est sur la table
d'opération
j'irai d'ailleurs à la demande de la
première ministre du président de la
République Laurent de visite tout à
l'heure préfecture de police et je sais
porter je sais porter le soutien unanime
de la représentation nationale
faut dire également que depuis six jours
les policiers et les gendarmes font face
et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure à 1500
1500 opérations non déclarées et je veux
d'ailleurs dire aujourd'hui qu'il n'est
pas dans l'état de droite de s'en
prendre à des bâtiments publics de
saccager des mairies
de mettre le feu à des préfectures
de jeter des cocktails Molotov sur les
gendarmes et sur les policiers et je
vous remercie de soutenir ces personnes
qui sont de véritables ouvriers de la
sécurité
[Musique]
je vous remercie de vous reste 3
secondes
silence s'il vous plaît allez-y mon cher
collègue vous comparez des dégradations
en bâtiments des violences sexistes et
sexuelles nous nous habiterons jamais à
votre invité monsieur
le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
[Musique]
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
je voudrais ici d'ailleurs
[Musique]
je voudrais ici d'ailleurs vous rappeler
que s'agissant des enquêtes de l'IGPN de
l'iggs sont conduites sous les
procureurs de la République et que
chacun devrait respecter la justice je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pourriez faire silence
s'il vous plaît pour que le prochain
orateur puisse exprimer
la parole est à Madame gratte-ciela
Melchior pour le gros Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Pape Ndiaye
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre depuis
hier et jusqu'à mercredi
536000 lycéens et lycéens des filières
générales et technologiques passent leur
épreuve de spécialité dans ma région en
Bretagne ce sont 26000 candidates et
candidats qui vont devoir plancher
histoire-géographie géopolitique et
sciences politiques humanité littérature
et philosophie mathématiques
physique-chimie par exemple ces matières
de spécialité qu'ils ont choisi compte
pour un tiers des résultats du bac et
seront pour la première fois prise en
compte dans parcoursup en effet depuis
la réforme du baccalauréat que nous
avons voté en 2019 ces épreuves ont été
supprimées du fait de la crise covid en
21 pour la même raison elles ont été
reportées en 2022 au mois de mai
retirant leur intérêt qui était d'aider
à départager les candidats dont
parcoursup en tant que professeur dans
l'enseignement supérieur en IUT je sais
que les notes de ces examens permettront
de disposer d'un indicateur objectif
pour évaluer le niveau d'un élève cette
épreuve en étant national et anonymisée
offre une garantie d'équité et limite
donc le biais discriminant qui pouvait
exister auparavant aussi malgré le
contexte social difficile il était
important que ces examens se tiennent et
je remercie l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative de cette engagée pour la
réussite des élèves et je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui encore elle sera prendre
ses responsabilités
nous l'avons vu hier dans l'ensemble la
journée s'est bien passée aussi Monsieur
le Ministre pouvez-vous nous indiquer ce
que le gouvernement a mis en place pour
permettre à toutes les lycéennes et à
tous les lycéens de passer leurs examens
dans des conditions sereine depuis hier
jusqu'à demain par ailleurs des craintes
ont été évoquées concernant un éventuel
blocage de la correction des copies dans
le cas de la mobilisation sociale
pouvez-vous là encore nous dire ce que
vous avez souhaité afin que les notes de
ces épreuves si important pour nos
jeunes soient bien pris en compte je
vous remercie je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
papenza et ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Melchior vous
l'avez dit pour la première fois les
résultats des deux épreuves de
spécialités seront pris en compte dans
la procédure parcoursup c'est important
puisque les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur auront des
résultats normés à l'échelle nationale
indépendante des variations selon les
lycées liés au contrôle continu et il
s'en réjouissent le programme les
programmes ont été adaptés nous allons
comme je l'ai indiqué précédemment voir
ce qu'il y a à ajuster pour la session
2024 mais je tiens d'ores et déjà à
saluer l'organisation générale du
baccalauréat qui se déroule sans faillir
jusqu'à présent tous les élèves ont pu
entrer il n'y a pas eu de blocage il n'y
a pas eu de difficultés de surveillance
et nous naissons pas de difficultés
particulières en ce qui concerne la
correction d'ici au 10 avril désormais
les élèves vont pouvoir se consacrer à
la préparation au grand oral également à
l'épreuve de philosophie qui
interviendront à peu près à la mi-juin
de telle sorte que leur avenir ne repose
plus comme avant sur une semaine
cruciale au mois de juin mais sur un
équilibre entre le contrôle continu et
des épreuves finales telle celle qu'ils
sont en train de passer à l'heure
actuelle encore une fois nous tirerons
le bilan mais jusqu'à présent nous avons
tout lieu de nous féliciter de
l'organisation générale des épreuves
cela se fait en bonne coordination
d'ailleurs avec en cas de blocage
éventuel mais ils n'ont pas lieu avec
les services des préfectures des forces
de l'ordre qui n'ont pas été mobilisées
mais enfin nous sommes évidemment prêts
à agir en cas de blocage pour l'instant
la situation est tout à fait
satisfaisante et nous avons tout lieu de
nous en féliciter je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre Morin pour
le rassemblement national
merci Madame la précédente madame la
Première ministre enfin pour le moment
pendant que vous essorez les Français
avec vos réformes injustes et brutales
les super profiteurs peuvent compter sur
votre complaisance coupable nous
disposons enfin du rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances sur
les concessions autoroutières et son
contenu spectaculaire explique peut-être
que vous l'ayez piteusement rangé dans
un placard depuis 2021 madame la
Première ministre une telle escroquerie
pourrait être classée au patrimoine du
grand banditisme d'État les autoroutes
françaises que l'État que l'État a
parfaitement suggéré jusqu'en 2005 ont
été vendus à ces grandes entreprises
pour un prix de session minorée de 8
millions d'euros en 2015 madame la
Première ministre votre implication dans
cette fraude est direct quand vous étiez
socialiste avec Emmanuel Macron vous
avez mis en œuvre avec ses sociétés un
plan de relance autoroutier en leur
faisant cadeau de trois ans de contrats
supplémentaires ce plan de relance
routier qui a permis à ses sociétés de
faire monter le taux de rentabilité des
actionnaires de 7 et demi à 12% a été
négocié par Alexis Kohler actuel
secrétaire général de l'Elysée et
vous-même résultat 15 milliards d'euros
de dividendes supplémentaires pour les
actionnaires vous avez même négocié avec
votre ancienne employeur puisque madame
la Première ministre vous avez dirigé le
service des concessions chez Eiffage
vous plaçant directement et
personnellement dans une situation de
conflit d'intérêts ce scandale indique
une réalité vous travaillez pour les
super profiteurs et contre les Français
qui payent chaque jour leur péage les
trois solutions pour vous rattraper
existe toutefois proposé par l'IGF une
fin anticipée des concessions en 2026
une baisse du prix des péages de 60% des
2022 vous êtes en retard le prélèvement
par l'état de 64% du bénéfice de ces
sociétés soit un total écoutez bien de
22,5 milliards d'euros d'ici 2026 ma
question est la suivante quel est votre
solution vous allez appliquer demain
pour rendre cet argent à son unique
propriétaire le peuple français merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'économie et des
finances
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur député Pierre Morin
visiblement vous confondez les millions
et les milliards ça n'est pas très
rassurant pour vos fonctions de
parlementaire heureusement que ce n'est
pas vous qui exercez le pouvoir dans
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
nous avons rendu public 15 rapports de
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
sur la gestion des autoroutes nous avons
avec le ministre des Transports depuis
deux ans fait en sorte que les tarifs
autoroutiers notamment en 2022 augmente
moins que l'inflation 2% 2022 et moins
que la façon pour les usagers en 2023 je
vous invite à participer à la commission
qui aura lieu demain commission des
affaires économiques auxquelles nous
participerons avec le ministre des
Transports où nous répondrons à toutes
les questions sur ce sujet en toute
transparence pour expliquer pour
expliquer notre politique sur les
autoroutes et moi je voudrais je
voudrais insister sur la solution
alternative que votre présidente propose
en matière d'autoroute vous avez proposé
Madame Le Pen la nationalisation des
autoroutes françaises et là ça ne coûte
pas 40 à 50 millions ça coûte 40 à 50
milliards d'euros à l'État français
c'est la double peine
c'est la peine pour le contribuable dont
on devra augmenter les impôts pour
rembourser les 40 à 50 milliards et
c'est la peine pour le climat car nous
avons mieux à faire qu'investir nous
état et nous pouvoir public dans les
autoroutes et dans le transport routier
nous voulons investir dans le transport
ferroviaire dans la décarbonation de
notre industrie ton industrie verte vous
regardez le passé nous regardons le
futur
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît la parole est à madame
la Présidente Chatelain pour le groupe
écologiste
madame la Première ministre partout se
multiplie les vidéos d'une violence
inouïe on y voit des manifestants
matraqués chargés sans consommation
claire exposé à des jets de la
crimonéenne quand ce ne sont pas des
grenades de désencerclement partout se
multiplier les témoignages de jeunes
gens cerclés par la police parfois
genoux à terre contre un mur les mains
sur la tête partout les situations de
Nas se multiplient on encercle on
contrôle on interpelle on intimide le 14
mars 4 étudiantes à Nantes ont porté
plainte pour agressions sexuelles par
des policiers on constate également le
retour des brigades de répression de
l'action violente motorisée qui ne se
sont pas sans rappeler les funestes
voltigeurs on constate que pour la seule
nuit de jeudi à Paris 292 personnes ont
été placées en garde de vue 97% de ces
arrestations étaient classées sans suite
80% de ces personnes privées de liberté
sans fondement votre gouvernement se
comporte comme un gouvernement assiéger
les Français vous font-ils madame la
Première ministre préférez-vous une
France pétrifiée à une France engagée
je vous remercie madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre
merci Madame l'après-midi Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Cyrielle châtelain
depuis des mois avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du socle nous avons bâti
un compromis sur la réforme des
retraites dans le respect de nos
institutions
[Applaudissements]
dès l'automne des concertations ont été
menées avec les organisations syndicales
et patronales et les groupes
parlementaires
elles nous ont permis d'élaborer notre
projet qui a été présenté aux Français
et au parlementaire en janvier le
compromis nous l'avons ensuite construit
pendant 175 heures de débat au Parlement
et lors de la commission mixte paritaire
avec des députés de la majorité et des
groupes de position nous avons débattu
échanger enrichit le texte mesdames et
messieurs les députés nous n'avons
jamais été aussi loin dans la
construction d'un compromis mais le
compromis madame la Présidente Chatelain
cela demande du courage tout comme
certaines réformes demandent de la
responsabilité pour agir agir pour
sauver notre système de retraite par
répartition pour revaloriser les petites
pensions pour permettre à ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt de partir plus
tôt pour prendre en compte les carrières
hachées c'est ça que nous avons
construit avec tous ceux qui veulent
sauver notre système de retraite par
répartition lorsque certains choisissent
la stratégie du chaos décrit des injures
comment pouvez-vous ensuite nous
reprocher que ce texte n'est pas pu être
examiné jusqu'à son terme et comment
osez-vous nous le reprochez et nous
reprocher la violence dans la rue face à
ces violences je veux à nouveau rendre
hommage à nos forces de l'ordre qui
assurent la sécurité des manifestations
et je le redis ils ont un devoir
d'exemplarité et ils ont sont conscients
nos policiers comme nos gendarmes et
tout signalement est examiné mais malgré
les violences malgré les outrages malgré
l'obstruction les mois de concertation
et de dialogue
ont permis d'aboutir à un texte
équilibré porteur de progrès pour les
Français
plus que jamais plus que jamais je suis
convaincu que c'est par le dialogue par
la recherche de compromis que nous
apporterons des solutions aux Français
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la Première ministre madame la
Présidente première ministre le seul
compromis que vous avez fait à priori
c'est avec votre conscience parce que
vous mentez sans honte à l'Assemblée
nationale vous encercler les Français et
vous montez sans honte en français car
oui vous cherchez à rendre la rue
silencieuse mais que vous faudra-t-il
pour les écouter des blessés des morts
madame la Première ministre je vous
demande solennellement de ne pas faire
le jeu de la répression pour cela il n'y
a qu'une solution le retrait de cette
réforme
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
la parole est un monsieur Olivier Faure
pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
parce son obstination le président de la
République a conduit le pays dans une
impasse sociale mais aussi politique
vous n'avez ni majorité populaire ni
majorité à l'Assemblée comme vous l'avez
vous-même avoué en reconnaissant à la
télévision que le compte n'y était pas
c'est en train de vous êtes en train de
fracturer notre pays et la seule unité
que vous réalisez c'est contre vous
rendez-vous compte hier 80% des sondés
déclarés souhaités que votre
gouvernement tombe votre mépris et votre
brutalité entraîne en écho des
manifestations auxquelles participent de
très nombreux jeunes le retour des
pelotons voltigeurs la présence d'unité
de police qui ne sont pas formés au
matin de l'ordre inquiète ou devrait
nous inquiéter toutes et tous ce sont
des enfants qui manifestent et qui font
face à des méthodes qui ont radicalement
changé depuis une semaine
qu'attendez-vous pour rendre les
Français le chaos pour un carnet l'ordre
attendez-vous un drame pour que vous
conveniez enfin que vous n'avez pas de
majorité sur cette réforme vous jouez
avec le feu
cette colère
cette colère ne s'arrêtera pas vous ne
pouvez pas faire vous ne pouvez pas
attendre que cela passe ça ne passera
pas cette colère c'est celle du monde du
travail les premiers de corvées que vous
avez vous-même célébré pendant la crise
sanitaire il demande maintenant à être
respecté et tous ici socialiste
communiste écologiste insoumis nous nous
battrons pour qu'ils le soient
effectivement
que veulent vos grands discours sur la
valeur de travail quand vous nous donnez
aucune valeur au travail
pour sortir du blocage vous n'avez plus
autre choix que le retrait ou le retour
au jugement du peuple puisque le
président aurait annoncé ne souhaitait
ni remaniement ni des solutions ni
référendum il ne reste que le retrait
alors ce que Jacques Chirac avait
compris vous devez le faire maintenant
on ne gouvernait jamais
[Applaudissements]
stop ministre du Travail de plein emploi
et de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente
et Messieurs le député monsieur le
député fort
si le député fort avec qui allez vous
faire croire que le Parti socialiste il
ne responsabilités reviendrait sur cette
réforme à personne à personne est-ce
qu'en 1997 le Parti socialiste est
revenu sur la réforme de 93 jamais
est-ce qu'en 2012 nous sommes revenus
sur la réforme 2010 pas plus au
contraire nous l'avons renforcé en
votant une engagement de la durée de
cotisation vous avez voté le passage à
43 ans vous l'avez voté et vous ne
l'assumez pas c'est grâce à la loi de
Marisol Touraine que les Français
doivent travailler plus longtemps et
Monsieur fort vous vous offusquez du
recours en 49-3 vous l'avez justifié en
2015 vous l'avez justifiée en 2016 sur
la loi travail vous parler des
travailleurs et des conditions de
travail je me souviens de vous en train
de justifier le 49-3 pour faire voter la
loi de Marie de Myriam el khomri
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Anne Gentet pour
le groupe Renaissance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez s'il vous plaît on écoute madame
je ne t'ai merci
Monsieur les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse ça m'a donné la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères je vais me permettre de si
vous voulez chers collègues bien on va
sortir un petit peu de nos frontières le
7 mars dernier
le 7 le 7 mars dernier la Géorgie
s'embrasait des milliers de manifestants
réclamaient le retrait de la loi dite
sur les agents étrangers je cite triste
réplique d'une loi promulguée il y a 10
ans en Russie dans l'objectif à peine
masqué de museler média opposition et
ONG le 7 mars dernier la Géorgie
s'embraset face à cette énième marque
d'influence voire d'ingérence russe dans
les affaires du pays une présence
étrangère matérialisée par l'occupation
d'une partie du territoire géorgien
depuis 2008 et qui s'est renforcé avec
l'installation de population russe qui
fuient la conscription et la guerre face
aux tentatives de ma mise russe un
horizon l'Union européenne la Géorgie a
affirmé quelques jours à peine après le
déclenchement de la guerre d'agression
en Ukraine menée par la Fédération de
Russie lorsqu'elle a présenté avec
l'Ukraine et la Moldavie une demande
d'adhésion en réponse au mois de juin le
Conseil européen a reconnu la
perspective européenne du conformément à
la vie de la commission la Géorgie doit
désormais avancer sur un certain nombre
de priorités dont le renforcement de la
lutte contre l'influence excessive des
oligarques et la dépolarisation
politique du pays à cet égard madame la
ministre alors que la Commission
européenne se prononcera prochainement
sur les progrès accomplis par le pays
pour répondre aux priorités en matière
de réforme recensée où en est la Géorgie
alors que la population géorgienne n'a
de cesse de nous rappeler son
attachement à l'Union européenne et que
nos pays entretiennent des relations
amicales anciennes quel rôle et quelles
initiatives pourraient être prises par
la France pour accompagner la Géorgie
dans cette voie et enfin comment
l'accompagner dans la résolution de la
question de la polarisation politique
alors quelle largement instrumentalisée
par le parti majoritaire rêve géorgien
et son leaders historique l'oligarque
Ivanishvili dans le groupe uscule d'ici
dans force du peuple n'est rien d'autre
que l'auteur de la loi contestée par les
agents étrangers je vous remercie
beaucoup la parole est à Catherine
Colonna ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
GNT le projet de loi sur les agents de
l'étranger que vous avez évoqué étaient
évidemment absolument
incompatible avec les valeurs de l'Union
européenne l'Union européenne que la
Géorgie aspire à rejoindre et à laquelle
le peuple géorgien une nouvelle fois
démontré son attachement profond de
façon pacifique d'ailleurs les messages
que nous avons passé avec les autres
États européens ont contribué à conduire
le Parlement géorgien à retirer ce
projet de loi ces choses faites et il
s'agit évidemment d'une décision
salutaire
elle doit conduire désormais la Géorgie
à poursuivre sans plus tarder les
réformes qui sont nécessaires pour
renforcer des tas de droits je l'ai dit
à plusieurs reprises je les ai
publiquement je l'ai dit également aux
autorités de Géorgie à sa présidente que
j'ai reçu il y a une quinzaine de jours
à Paris et à mon homologue ministre des
Affaires étrangères de Géorgie le statut
de candidat à l'Union européenne passe
par des profondes réforme
l'aspiration des Géorgiens est à plus
d'état de droits plus de liberté pour la
société civile pour les médias et pour
les ONG vous l'avez dit en un mot plus
de ses valeurs qui sont celles de
l'Europe et cette aspiration du peuple
géorgien il nous revient aussi de la
préserver face aux tentatives de
déstabilisation nous en avons vu
quelques-unes et je voudrais rappeler la
présence illégale de troupes russes
en Géorgie comme en Moldavie je l'ai
d'ailleurs souligné hier à mon arrivée à
Bruxelles à la réunion des 27 ministres
des Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne la France continuera donc à
accompagner la Géorgie dans la voie
européenne sur le chemin des réformes et
elle doit savoir pouvoir compter sur
notre amitié sur notre vigilance
également et sur notre soutien pour y
parvenir je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est à Madame Caroline Parmentier pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de la Culture
madame la ministre je me suis rendu au
Palais de Tokyo pour dénoncer le tableau
de Myriam Kahn qui présente aux yeux de
tous une scène de pédocrinalité ce
tableau représente un enfant à genoux
ligoté les mains dans le dos forcé à une
fellation par un adulte rien ne justifie
l'exposition d'une telle œuvre pas même
le prétexte de la dénonciation des
crimes de guerre ce tableau à caractère
ouvertement pédopornographique est
exposé dans la sphère publique sans
interdiction aux mineurs depuis le 17
février dans un musée du 16e
arrondissement rappelons que nous-mêmes
et d'autres associations de protection
de l'enfance si nous n'avions pas
dénoncé l'exposition des dessins de
Bastien Vivès il aurait été exposé cette
année au Festival de la BD d'Angoulême
son exposition a été annulée il est
désormais sous le coup d'une enquête
préliminaire de la brigade de protection
des mineurs pour diffusion d'images
pédopornographiques comme la rappeler
l'association innocence en danger qui a
demandé le retrait de la toile le
tableau de Myriam Kahn nuit gravement à
nos valeurs communes et au combat pour
la protection de l'enfance en tant que
membre de la commission des affaires
culturelles en tant que membre de la
délégation au droit des enfants mais
surtout en tant que femme et en tant que
mère je vous demande madame la ministre
si l'exposition de ce genre de tableau
sera l'un des marqueurs de votre mandat
un glissement vers la démocratisation et
l'acceptation de ce type d'oeuvre et si
ce n'est pas le cas je vous le demande
solennellement quand ce tableau va-t-il
être décroché
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Réma de Malak ministre de la Culture
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Parmentier ne mélangeons pas tout le
combat pour la protection de l'enfance
et contre toutes les formes de violence
on le mène tous collectivement au
gouvernement aux côtés de ma collègue
Charlotte cobel tous les jours
ce tableau de quoi s'agit-il
c'est un tableau d'une artiste suisse
Myriam Khan son exposition au Palais de
Tokyo artiste de 73 ans qui depuis 40
ans
documente et dénonce les horreurs de la
guerre
c'est son intention vous êtes allé faire
votre coup de com et filmer ce tableau
mais est-ce que vous avez vu l'ensemble
de l'exposition est-ce que vous avez
échangé avec les médiateurs est-ce que
vous avez lu les explications parce
qu'on peut pas sortir une oeuvre de son
contexte
l'intention de l'artiste est diamètre
allemand opposé diamétralement opposé à
l'interprétation que vous en faites pour
elle c'est une dénonciation des crimes
de guerre voilà ce qu'elle dit ce ne
sont pas des enfants qui sont
représentés ce tableau traite de la
façon dont la sexualité est utilisée
comme arme de guerre comme crime contre
l'humanité le contraste entre les deux
corps figure la puissance corporelle de
l'oppresseur et la fragilité de
l'opprimée la répétition des images de
violence dans les guerres vise à
dénoncer oui l'art peut choquer peut
questionner peut parfois susciter du
malaise voire du dégoût là n'est pas
consensuel et la liberté d'expression et
de création est garantie par la loi vous
avez toute liberté d'interpréter
l'oeuvre comme vous voulez
ce n'est ni à une ministre ni à une
parlementaire en revanche de qualifier
une infraction pénale c'est le rôle de
la justice c'est le rôle de la justice
[Musique]
je vous remercie madame la ministre
madame Parmentier il suffit donc que
l'artiste décrète que ce n'est pas un
enfant alors que c'est clairement un
enfant pour qu'il soit dédouané en
réalité comme la rappeler l'Association
des juristes pour l'enfance peu importe
les allégations ou même les intentions
de l'artiste elle ne permettent pas
d'échapper à la qualification pénale
dans la mesure où le plus grand nombre
reconnaît bien la représentation d'un
enfant dans cette figure à genouillée et
violée madame la ministre mon nom de
tous les enfants abusés vous devriez
avoir honte de ce que vous venez de dire
la parole
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît la parole est à monsieur
le Président pencheur pour le groupe
yote
je m'adresse à vous solennellement quant
allez vous retirer la réforme des
retraites voulues par Emmanuel Macron
prenez vous la mesure du péril que
traverse notre pays les Français sont
inquiets en colère vous aviez fait le
pari qu'une fois la réforme passée la
situation se calmerait elle devient au
contraire incontrôlable le résultat du
vote de la motion de censure
transpartisane portée par notre groupe
est un séisme politique merci à ceux qui
l'ont accompagné certes il a manqué
quelques voix mais qui aurait pu parier
sur un résultat si étriqué mesurez-vous
l'opposition à cette réforme opposition
des organisations syndicales opposition
de l'assemblée qui aurait
majoritairement voté contre ce texte
opposition des Français pour qu'il la
réforme est injuste est inefficace faute
d'avoir répondu aux manifestations
pacifiques d'une ampleur inédite nous
assistons et une radicalisation du
mouvement les forces de l'ordre sont à
crans faute d'écoute et de véritables
débats le chaos risque d'emporter notre
pays notre démocratie est en danger nous
ne voulons pas du chaos mais et nous
vous faisons des propositions à travers
vous madame la Première ministre c'est
au président Macron que parlementaires
du groupe lyaute s'adresse il est encore
temps d'éteindre l'incendie qu'il a
déclenché nous lui demandons de ne pas
promulguer ce projet de loi dans le cas
contraire il doit redonner la parole à
nos concitoyens par un référendum ce
n'est malheureusement pas le choix qu'il
semble faire cette loi retirée et il
faut le faire Emmanuel Macron devra
retrouver le chemin de la Concorde à
travers la consultation des forces
politiques sociales des groupes
parlementaires et des élus locaux nous
devons déterminer et décider enfin
ensemble des gants de réformes amener
pour notre pays changer de méthode et de
cap nous ne pouvons pas continuer ainsi
pendant quatre ans tout le monde le sait
ici madame la Première ministre
vous-même et le président Macron y êtes
vous prêt allez-vous écouter les
Français la représentation nationale
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Bertrand pencher
hier le texte construit par les
parlementaires après plusieurs semaines
de débat et un accord en commission
mixte paritaire à achevé son parcours
législatif
ce texte de compromis garantit l'avenir
de nos retraites et vous aurez beau
affirmer l'inverse monsieur le Président
crier à l'absence de dialogue et vous
assurer ainsi quelques heures de gloire
la réalité pourtant bien celle-ci le
texte sur lequel j'ai engagé ma
responsabilité et celui d'un compromis
parlementaire
cette réforme monsieur le Président
penchère est nécessaire pour assurer
l'avenir de notre système de retraite
par répartition et nous avons travaillé
avec des parlementaires sur tous les
bancs à la rendre plus juste avec votre
groupe le groupe lot nous avons
travaillé et trouver des compromis
notamment pour l'application de la
réforme dans les outre-mer
je suis bien consciente des efforts que
demande cette réforme je suis bien
consciente de l'inquiétude qu'elle peut
susciter et je connais les
revendications des mouvements sociaux
c'est pourquoi avec mon gouvernement
avec les parlementaires qui veulent agir
pour nos concitoyens avec les
territoires et nos élus locaux avec les
partenaires sociaux nous voulons
répondre aux inquiétudes des Français
les rassembler et apporter des solutions
efficaces et concrètes nous devons
répondre aux interrogations que ce
projet de réforme des retraites a mis en
lumière sur notre rapport au travail sur
l'égalité des chances sur notre capacité
à offrir à chacun des perspectives
professionnelles nous avons tous notre
rôle à jouer alors monsieur le Président
pencher il est temps de sortir des
postures je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Madame clémence guettet
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique
cette semaine est celle de la censure
populaire censure de vos agissements
anti-démocratiques permis par la
Cinquième République censure aussi de
votre action anti-écologique encouragée
par le capitalisme le rapport du GIEC
sorti hier nous alerte un site très
clairement
75% des habitants de cette planète
pourrait souffrir de vagues de chaleur
meurtrière à l'horizon 2100 partout dans
le monde le rythme normal des
précipitations et des saisons laissent
place à un enchaînement d'événements
climatiques extrêmes en France après des
étés sans pluie une sécheresse hivernale
a mis le niveau des nappes au plus bas
cela rend donc obsolète les fameuses
bassines pas encore construites mais
dont vous voulez pourtant recouvrir le
pays
ce weekend nous serons donc des milliers
dans la Vienne et les Deux-Sèvres pour
défendre le droit à l'eau et pour dire
NON
Oméga bassine de substitution
contre un modèle insensé que vous voulez
imposer en dépit de toutes les alertes
nous sommes le front de la résistance
écoutez les hydrologues les agronomes
les paysans qui vous disent qu'il faut
permettre le remplissage des nappes
phréatiques en finir avec les
monocultures destinées à l'export et
empêcher l'accaparement de l'eau au
profit d'une minorité et l'explosion de
son prix pour tous en effet aujourd'hui
deux chemins s'ouvrent devant nous
l'adaptation ou la poursuite de la
prédation le partage ou le pillage
l'agriculture vivrière ou l'agro
industrie délétère vous les spécialistes
du passage en force vous devez pourtant
rendre des comptes au peuple sur ce
choix mais comme pour les retraites vous
optez pour la brutalité du droit à l'eau
à Sainte-Soline et à Moser aux droits de
grève à Vitry et à Fos-sur-Mer vous
criminalisez les Français qui résistent
en espérant dissimuler votre propre
inaction climatique et vos attaques
antisociales monsieur le ministre le
peuple ne veut ni des bassines ni de
votre monde écoutez-le
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
bechut ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la Présidente m'a l'air de la
Premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les députés madame la députée Clémence
guetter sécheresse hivernale rapport du
GIEC pointant le fait que avec le
dérèglement climatique nous devrons nous
préparer avoir entre 10 et 40 % d'eau en
moins travaux sur l'adaptation qui
viennent d'être lancés par le
gouvernement sur les quatre degrés j'y
reviendrai et dans quelques jours vous
avez raison des manifestations qui sont
entendues sur un sujet qui est crucial
et qui est celui du partage en eau qui
est objectivement est au cœur des enjeux
de la transition écologique il n'y a pas
d'agriculture sans eau
l'hypocrisie qui consisterait à déporter
notre empreinte en eau ailleurs avec des
conditions qui empêchaient les
agriculteurs ici de produire n'est ni
responsable ni courageux la meilleure
retenue c'est la nappe phréatique la
meilleure solution c'est la sobriété
mais il y a autant de situations qu'il y
a de territoire à Sainte Soline
protocole en 2018 y compris validé par
une députée de la nupaise madame bateau
conditionnement de la recharge de la
nappe phréatique à des baisses de
prélèvement et à des baisses de
pesticides et dans cette histoire qui
stérilise le débat
vous êtes en train vous êtes en train de
donner des leçons dans un contexte où la
dernière manifestation elle a débouché
sur 61 gendarmes blessé par des boules
de pétanque visé par des tirs de
mortiers et par des jets de pierre et
préventivement ici même vous dressez les
Français les uns contre les autres vous
radicalisez vous simplifier tout à
l'extrême en faisant comme si tout était
noir et blanc et en prenant le pari du
chaos du désordre et de la menace à tous
azimut
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente
cette question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'État auprès du ministre des
Armées chargée des anciens combattants
et de la mémoire madame la secrétaire
d'État
il y a quasiment 69 ans jour pour jour
regroupés dans la cuvette de diennes fou
les troupes françaises Cécile combat
fidèles au mot de leur commandant en
chef le général Navarre il faut laisser
le feu mourir de lui-même mais ne pas
capituler ne pas lever le drapeau blanc
de nombreux militaires français
légionnaires ou servant au sein de
bataillon de parachutistes coloniaux
avait perdu la vie dans un combat au
cours duquel le courage des belligérants
des deux côtés devaient conduire au
respect réciproque gardons leurs
souvenirs et leur mémoire
les conditions de départ des troupes
françaises n'ont pas permis de donner
une sépulture digne et descente à tous
ceux qui ont donné leur vie à une terre
que beaucoup d'entre eux aimaient
profondément les années qui ont passé
nous ont permis de parcourir avec la
République socialiste du Vietnam un
chemin conduisant à marquer en 2023 le
double anniversaire des 50 ans de nos
relations diplomatiques et des 10 ans de
notre partenariat stratégique le 3
novembre 2018 le Premier ministre
Edouard Philippe s'était rendu sur les
mémoriaux présents sur place pour
délivrer un message d'admiration de
respect et de fierté le développement de
la zone de Diane bien fou conduite
aujourd'hui à un projet d'extension de
l'aéroport situé sur le site des
affrontements selon le Souvenir français
ces travaux pourraient conduire à mettre
à jour et profaner plus d'une centaine
de dépouilles des soldats ayant combattu
sur ce site madame la secrétaire d'État
dans le respect de la souveraineté de
l'État vietnamien le gouvernement
français envisage-t-il une action
permettant de préserver les tombes
souvent sommaires de ces soldats qui ont
donné leur vie
sur ordre du gouvernement français et de
leur chef un rapatriement de ses
dépouilles est-il envisagé je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Patricia mirales
secrétaire d'État chargé des anciens
combattants et de la mémoire merci
madame le Président Monsieur le Député
Pradal je vous remercie pour cette
question qui va me permettre de rétablir
l'effet et d'éteindre les polémiques que
certains voudraient lancer en
méconnaissance des principes qui ont
toujours toujours guidé l'action de
l'État en la matière car le principe est
clair la France a une obligation de
sépultures perpétuelles pour tous ceux
qui sont morts pour elle elle est
inscrite dans la loi de la Première
Guerre mondiale sauf bien entendu
lorsque les familles souhaitent
récupérer les corps dans le cas
particulier du Vietnam une doctrine
s'est forgée dans le temps en accord
avec le gouvernement vietnamien et avec
les associations de combattants les
corps doivent être rapatriés en
métropole dans la nécropole du Mémorial
des guerres en Indochine à Fréjus
les associations de combattants m'ont
confirmé encore la semaine dernière
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas que nous
dérogeons à cette règle bien établie
pour la guerre d'Indochine cela
nécessite dans un premier temps
d'organiser avec les autorités
vietnamiennes les modalités
d'information de l'ambassade et de
conservation des corps lors de leur
découverte je sais que les autorités
vietnamiennes sont particulièrement
vigilantes et respectueuse sur ce point
dans un second temps il convient
d'organiser concrètement les modalités
de rapatriement en mettant à jour
l'accord franco-vie vietnamien qui date
de 1986 relative au rapatriement des
corps de militaires français au Vietnam
la France n'oublie aucun de ses
combattants quel que soit le nombre
d'années ou des kilomètres qui nous
séparent de leur sacrifices c'est dans
cet esprit que je serai présente le 8
juin pour la journée nationale d'hommage
aux morts pour la France en Indochine à
la nécropole du Mémorial national de
Fréjus les dépouilles seront retrouvés à
Diane benfou ou ailleurs au Vietnam et
retrouveront leurs frères dames qui sont
déjà au Mémorial merci je vous remercie
madame la ministre
la parole est un monsieur Charles
Fournier pour le trop écologiste madame
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la première
ministre en charge de la planification
écologique après 8 ans de travaux le
GIEC a publié hier son rapport et il est
formel les politiques actuellement en
œuvre y compris en France nous mène à un
réchauffement de 3,2 degrés à l'horizon
de 2100 chaque fraction de degré
supplémentaire est une menace pour les
écosystèmes et pour la santé humaine les
risques s'intensifient et les plus
vulnérables en paix déjà le prix il y a
urgence à agir pourtant aucune réaction
de la part du président de la République
peut-être demain au 13h aucune réaction
de votre part suite à la publication du
rapport du GIEC nous l'avons dit nous
l'avons répété retraite et climat même
combat car derrière la réforme des
retraites se cache les stigmates du
tout-productivisme qui vous guide
aveuglement travaillez plus pour
produire et consommer toujours plus peu
importe les limites planétaires c'est
aussi pour cela que les jeunes sont dans
la rue la France se croit une bonne
élève climatique mais vous êtes dans le
même déni que dédale homme de tous les
talents dont la ventivité l'arrogance
lui font croire que la technique va
pouvoir réparer les problèmes qu'il a
créé vous connaissez la suite avec le
Minotaure et le mythe d'Icare au
problème vous avez toujours une solution
technique une solution numérique à la
décarbonation vous répondez nous vos EPR
et SMR au problème de sécheresse vous
répondez méga bassine ce techno
optimisme est un danger il ne vise qu'à
sauver celles et ceux qui depuis des
décennies ont vu abîmer notre avenir la
bifurcation que nous défendons porte une
transformation systémique et radicale
qui s'appuie sur les préconisations du
GIEC donnez la priorité à la justice
climatique et sociale porter des
processus de 36 transition juste des
mesures d'atténuation et un modèle
soutenable alors si comme le dit
Monsieur Béchu on risque une France à 4
degrés je vous pose la question quel est
votre plan d'urgence pour la transition
écologique
quand allez-vous soumettre au Parlement
une loi énergique climat qui soit digne
de ce nom je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Agnès
panier rue naché ministre de la
transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Fournier le rapport du GIEC confirme
l'extrême urgence à agir pour atteindre
les objectifs de l'accord de Paris vous
avez raison et Monsieur le Député je
sais que nous retrouvons sur ce constat
et la nécessité de prendre en main cette
course contre la montre mais là où vous
êtes dans la terre moi nous nous sommes
dans l'action c'est cette majorité qui
est ce gouvernement qui ont doublé la
vitesse de baisse des gaz et émission de
cerf lors du précédent quinquennat c'est
cette majorité et ce gouvernement qui
ont porté lorsqu'ils avaient la
présidence française le texte le plus
ambitieux en matière climatique
internationale qui est le paquet climat
feat for fifty-five c'est ce
gouvernement et cette Premier ministre
qui ont promulgué une loi sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables que vous n'avez pas voté
alors que vous alliez du Parti
socialiste en responsabilité et son
compromission eux ont fait le choix de
la voter c'est ce gouvernement qui porte
un projet de loi sur le nucléaire
énergie que le GIEC lui-même indique
comme étant utile à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique si vous alliez
lire dans le détail les rapports du GIEC
mais vous ne le faites pas vous êtes
dans le coup d'éclat et que vous n'allez
pas voter alors moi je suis très claire
j'invite l'ensemble des députés de cette
hémicycle tout à l'heure à prendre le
destin climatique de la France en main à
voter pour le projet de loi nucléaire
pour le climat pour la planète mais
aussi pour notre indépendance
énergétique je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur de
l'autre aide pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
est-ce qu'il faut reculer l'âge de la
retraite qui est aujourd'hui de 62 ans
je ne crois pas quant aujourd'hui on est
peu qualifié quand on vit dans une
région qui est en difficulté
industrielle quand on est soi-même en
difficulté qu'on a une carrière
fracturée bon courage déjà pour arriver
à 62 ans c'est ça la réalité de notre
pays ces mots madame la Première
ministre sont se prononcer par Emmanuel
Macron le 25 avril 2019 à l'issue du
grand débat national auriez-vous depuis
perdu tous sens des réalités en passant
au forceps votre réforme qui plus est
dans le mépris le plus total de la
représentation nationale à l'Assemblée
comme au Sénat dans le mépris du
dialogue social tout syndicat confondu
et pire encore dans le mépris des
Françaises et des Français qui se sont
jusque la mob isés pacifiquement par
millions dans les cortèges
c'était sans compter sur votre ultime
recours au 49.3 qui a ouvert une
nouvelle séquence et à laquelle vous ne
répondez pas si ce n'est par la
répression au risque d'embraser le
mouvement vous portez là une lourde
responsabilité sur vos épaules alors
madame la Première ministre allez-vous
enfin entendre raison allez-vous oui ou
non retirez votre loi qui ne convaincue
personne
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
au ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député de l'autre aide la loi telle
qu'elle a été adoptée par le Parlement
après le rejet des deux motions de
censure est une loi qui vient après 4
mois de concertation et qui vient après
175 heures de débats de débats ici et le
seul mépris pour le Parlement monsieur
le député le seul mépris c'est lorsqu'on
organise une obstruction systématique
lorsqu'on dépose 20 000 amendements
juste pour priver le Parlement de sa
capacité à débattre ça n'a pas été le
cas au Sénat et ça permet un examen
complet de la loi cette loi monsieur le
député va permettre de revaloriser les
petites retraites ça permet de mieux
prévenir l'usure professionnelle de
mieux prendre en compte la pénibilité ça
permet de mieux accompagner les
carrières longues ça permet de mieux
aider le retour et de maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors est-ce que vous ne
voulez pas être d'accord avec ça est-ce
que vous ne voulez pas accompagner cette
mise en oeuvre justement pour apporter
des réponses des fois en sorte que notre
système de retraite soit préservé
protégé parce que ce système de retraite
il est utile à ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles pas à ce contour à ceux qui
sont les plus fragiles et c'est eux que
nous pensons quand on travaille à sa
pérennisation je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
monsieur de la traite monsieur le
ministre au passage en force nous
préférons la démocratie alors si vous
croyez à ce que vous dites à défaut
d'entendre la représentation nationale
laisser les Françaises et les Français
ont décidé par la voix d'un référendum
madame la Première ministre a semer la
misère vous prenez le risque de récolter
la tempête
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur Alexandre portier pour le
groupe la républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre je ne prendrais que
un chiffre et un exemple le chiffre
c'est 1500 1500 postesignant que vous
allez supprimer à la rentrée prochaine à
l'heure où nos classes sont déjà les
plus surchargées de toute l'Europe
l'exemple c'est l'école de trad un petit
village du Haut-Beaujolais dont je suis
le député trad ou la commune investit
plus de 150 000 euros ces dernières
années
une école ou des générations entières de
familles se sont succédées et une école
surtout aux résultats que l'on enverrait
partout en France nous avons même un
champion de lecture qui va porter nos
couleurs au niveau départemental dans
quelques semaines c'est une vraie fierté
pour tout ce village mais voilà cette
école n'a cette année que neuf élèves
alors évidemment on s'empresse de la
fermer dans quatre ans elle sera revenue
à 15 élèves le Rhône gagne des habitants
ces effectifs ne ont cessé de remonter
mais au lieu de proposer des pistes pour
soutenir l'école durant ce creux on
s'empresse de faire une croix dessus
partout en France au lieu d'alléger les
classes vous enfermez c'est à mon sens
absolu et puis surtout vous fermez les
classes mais sans jamais nous dire
combien au total en France elle
s'annonce par centaines à la ville comme
à la campagne dans les petits villages
comme trad mais aussi à Paris provoquant
la colère des élus des maires des
parents des enseignants alors je vous
pose la question monsieur le ministre
dites nous aujourd'hui clairement
combien de classes vous allez fermer à
la rentrée par tout en France et pour le
Haut Beaujolais monsieur le ministre
renoncerez-vous enfin à condamner non
seulement l'école mais aussi surtout le
village de trad son dernier commerce et
les familles qui viennent de s'y
installer je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Papa
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député portier votre question s'inscrit
évidemment comme vous le savez dans un
contexte qui est celui d'une baisse très
importante des effectifs scolaires à
l'échelle du pays dans votre département
c'est moins 3000 élèves que nous
comptons à la rentrée
2023 par parenthèse vous noterez que ces
baisses de postes d'effectif coïncide
donc avec des baisses d'effectifs
scolaires contrairement à certaines
périodes par exemple entre 2007 et 2012
quand il y avait des baisses de poste
c'est une croissance des effectifs
scolaires mais cela est sans doute
secondaire j'en reviens à mon point
principal c'est le fait que nous devons
et là je vous conseille de ce point nous
devons du côté du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale faire mieux en
matière de pluri annualité de manière à
ce que les communes
particulier puisse envisager leurs
investissements y compris leurs
investissements bâtimentaires dans une
perspective relativement longue les
enfants qui naissent aujourd'hui sont
les enfants qui seront scolarisés dans
trois ans exactement et donc nous
travaillons au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale sur des perspectives pluries
annuelles en lien bien entendu et en
collaboration et en échange avec les
collectivités le deuxième point que je
voudrais souligner c'est le fait que
nous devons penser les questions de
ruralité de manière globale et c'est
pour cela que j'échange et que je
travaille avec ma collègue Dominique
Faure de manière à ne pas penser en silo
les services de l'État mais à les
pensées dans leur globalité et enfin le
dernier point que je voudrais souligner
c'est le fait que nous en sommes
actuellement au mois de mars que des
ajustements ont lieu actuellement
jusqu'au mois de juin et jusqu'aux
ajustements finaux du mois d'août ce qui
m'interdit de répondre précisément à
votre question à ce stade je pourrais le
faire au mois d'août merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre me supportiez vous
ne répondez pas à la question c'est bien
dommage et surtout vous ne pouvez pas
justifier les fermetures de classe par
une baisse de la démographie scolaire
pas quand nous avons les classes les
plus surchargées d'Europe et de toute
l'OCDE et puis surtout il faut se dire
la vérité les classes que l'on ferme
elle ne réouvre jamais par contre les
villages qui sont morts eux le sont
durablement
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Laure Miller pour
le groupe Renaissance
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
transition écologique monsieur
Christophe Béchu monsieur le ministre le
GIEC a publié hier son sixième rapport
le constat est clair et prend la forme
d'une alerte si des efforts ont été
engagés nous devons nécessairement aller
plus loin et surtout aller plus vite ce
rapport est aussi au dire même du
président du GIEC un message d'espoir
message d'espoir car je cite nous avons
le savoir-faire la technologie les
outils et les ressources financières
pour surmonter les problèmes climatiques
que nous avons identifié autre message
important ce rapport notre
investissement dans la transition
écologique sera forcément gagnant les
bénéfices d'une limitation du
réchauffement à 2 degrés seront plus
importants que les coûts que cela
causerait à l'humanité de s'assurer un
futur vivable après le fameux point de
basculement nous pouvons je le crois
chers collègues nous féliciter que pour
la première fois un président de la
République était élu en 2022 sur un
projet de planification écologique et
sur l'idée de nous fixer enfin une
trajectoire claire ambitieuse secteur
par secteur territoire par territoire un
fin remarqué l'ensemble des forces vives
de notre pays et de relever
collectivement ce défi sur les questions
énergétiques en particulier notre
assemblée est à l'oeuvre et la
planification est en cours nous marchons
sur nos deux pieds d'une part
l'accélération du renouvelable et de
l'autre part l'accélération du nucléaire
d'autre part mais ce que nous dit aussi
le GIEC c'est et c'est le sens de ma
question c'est que c'est transformation
de fond ont plus de chances de porter
leur fruit lorsque règne la confiance
lorsque tout le monde collabore pour se
concentrer sur la réduction des risques
et lorsque les avantages et les charges
se répartissent équitablement alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
double à quel niveau d'avancement
sommes-nous dans la mise en place de
cette planification écologique et
surtout comment garantir que celle-ci se
fasse de la façon la plus juste possible
autrement dit comment éviter une
transition écologique vécue comme
punitive par nos concitoyens je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la député Miller je voudrais d'abord au
lendemain de la publication de ce
rapport rendre hommage à Valérie Masson
Delmotte qui depuis 8 ans préside un des
groupes de travail du GIEC de ce 6e
cycle parce que son investissement en
France au sein du au conseil pour le
climat mais plus largement sur le plan
mondial et crucial il y a très peu de
femmes de surcroît qui ont assumé cette
responsabilité encore moins de français
et je voudrais doublement les saluer
après avoir dit ça le rapport il dit
d'abord qu'on peut nier le réchauffement
climatique ni n'y est son origine
humaine à un moment où les réseaux
sociaux sont en train de faire face à
une résurgence des fake news et d'un
climato-scepticisme qui se généralise
deuxièmement
le rapport insiste sur le fait qu'il
faut accélérer sur l'atténuation puisque
même les pays qui ont commencé à baisser
leurs émissions c'est le cas de la
France ne sont pas dans le bon rythme
nous devons doubler le rythme de baisse
de nos émissions dans ce quinquennat par
rapport au quinquet la précédente
comment on fait avec la planification
écologique avec des feuilles de
décarbonation par secteur qui sont en
train d'être assemblés sous l'autorité
de la première ministre et avec une
stratégie énergétique qui repose sur des
énergies non carbonées le renouvelable
et le nucléaire de manière à éviter les
erreurs allemandes avec la réouverture
des mines de charbon que nous
connaissons à l'heure actuelle enfin le
rapport dit et ça ne s'oppose pas que
quel que soit les efforts que les pays
feront à la minute où nous sommes nous
ne sommes pas sur la bonne trajectoire
et ça vient pleinement valider le choix
que j'ai fait validé par la première
ministre d'adapter notre pays à une
augmentation des températures qui
pourraient atteindre 4 degrés à la fin
de ce siècle ça n'est pas du défaitisme
c'est du réalisme qui nous permet à la
fois d'accélérer sur l'atténuation et de
faire en sorte de conduire les
investissements qui sont nécessaires je
peux comprendre que pour certains dans
un souci de simplisme et de caricature
politique parce qu'on marche sur leur
plate-bande il fasse comme ça n'existait
pas la vraie écologie c'est pas celle
des discours c'est celle de l'action je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur Marcelin
Nadaud pour le groupe GDR
merci
[Applaudissements]
le ministre délégué aux outre-mer
monsieur le ministre madame la Première
ministre a refusé de rencontrer 19
députés des 10 outre-mer le gouvernement
a rejeté par le biais de l'article 49.3
la plupart des mesures votées à
l'unanimité lors de l'examen de la
mission outre-mer du projet de loi de
finance 2023
pas une loi votée par cet assemblée n'a
été consacré depuis le premier
quinquennat de l'actuel président de la
République au 10 outre-mer y compris sur
les retraites vous gérez donc nos
territoires par ordonnance extrait
démocratique nous députés des 10
outre-mer avant depuis le début de cette
législature essuyé un refus de la part
de ce gouvernement de prendre en compte
les spécificités des problématiques de
nos territoires et voici que par arrêter
vous monsieur le ministre délégué aux
outre-mer vous avez choisi de vous
séparer de collaborateurs il est établi
par de nombreux observateurs que le seul
temps de cette ex-conseillé et d'avoir
voulu dialoguer avec les petits
planteurs de bananes autour de leurs
difficultés et c'est à la demande des
grands propriétaires terriens et des
lobbies de l'import-export que vous
auriez pris la décision de remercier ce
monsieur alors monsieur le ministre
est-il vrai que vous avez agi sur ordre
des lobbys dont personne n'ignore en
dépit de l'unique décision de non-lieu
la part de responsabilité dans le
scandale du clan des cônes cela
montrerait donc la collusion de votre
gouvernement avec les puissances
oligarchiques monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour sortir à la fois
de la tyrannie de l'indifférence comme
dirait aimer Césaire vis-à-vis de nos
territoires et de cette relation
empreinte de colonialité entre l'État et
les lobbys dans nos pays
[Applaudissements]
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés marcelona do vous l'aurez
constaté je ne suis pas Jean-François
caraco
et je l'excuse sans son absence je crois
lui-même qu'il est actuellement en
déplacement en territoire
ultramarin
je vais essayer de circonscrire la
réponse à un élément factuel de votre
question monsieur le député qui portait
sur les petits planteurs de bananes si
vous en êtes d'accord parce que je crois
comprendre à travers de votre question
que ça pourrait être l'objet de la
discorde
d'abord rappeler que la filière des
petits planteurs de bananes est une
filière qui compte dans les Antilles
puisque un actif antillais sur 20
travaille dans cette filière la filière
contextuellement sur le les deux
territoires confondus 600 exploitations
familiales et elle fait face aujourd'hui
à des enjeux qui nécessitent
effectivement une intervention
notamment la cercosporioz noir qui est
une maladie qui peut toucher les bananes
mais également le réchauffement
climatique qui a également un impact sur
cette filière importante où la forte
augmentation des coûts de production
face à cela plusieurs mesures ont été
prises pour venir en aide aux
exploitants parmi lesquels la reprise de
50% de la dette des exploitants sur
leurs achats engagés avec un plafond de
15000 euros et un étalement sur trois
ans de la dette restante l'aide à la
relance de 3000 euros par hectare le
projet de construction de 4 stations de
conditionnement collectives ultra
moderne principalement destiné au petit
planteur
pourquoi je vous réponds là-dessus parce
que vous avez semblé un criminé
le départ d'un collaborateur de mon
collègue ministre délégué en charge de
l'outre-mer sur la base des relations
qu'il aurait avec les planteurs etc je
vous dis juste pardonnez-moi pour
remettre les faits au milieu du village
les actions qui sont conduites
actuellement par l'État pour venir en
aide au petit planteur de bananes par
ailleurs il y aura d'autres engagements
qui ont été pris par le Président de la
République et qui vont se poursuivre
dans leur application dans la
concertation d'une part avec des
trajectoires d'autonomie alimentaire
adaptées aux besoins locaux et d'autre
part impact et une loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole je vous remercie
monsieur le député je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Laurent Pagny foot pour le
groupe yote merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Industrie monsieur le
ministre à l'Ariège le territoire de
l’avené Laroque-d'Olmes Mirepoix est un
des plus sinistrés de France victimes de
la crise industrielle dans les textiles
avec plusieurs milliers d'emplois
industriels perdus mais c'est aussi un
bassin qui fait preuve de résilience et
puis qui peut compter sur l'appui et le
dynamisme de la région Occitanie du
département et de ses intercommunalités
cette résilience a permis notamment à
nos entreprises de s'adapter et réagir
rapidement pendant la crise sanitaire en
se réinventant pour mettre à profit leur
savoir-faire et leur expertise dans le
textile elles ont permis de produire
rapidement les masques blues et autres
produits qui faisaient alors cruellement
défaut car cette pandémie a mis à jour
une cruelle réalité la
désindustrialisation massive de notre
pays et notamment en ce qui concerne les
produits stratégiques l'exemple des
masques est blues et frappant bien sûr
mais il en va de même pour les
médicaments ou les composants
électroniques
ces entreprises qui ont assuré les
livraisons en urgence quand nous en
avions le plus besoin ces entreprises
qui représentent l'avenir des filières
traditionnelles sur nos territoires se
sont vu tout simplement écartés de la
commande publique une fois la crise
terminée comme si rien ne s'était passé
alors même qu'elle propose une
fabrication durable respectueuse des
exigences environnementales lors des
appels d'offres émis par nos
administrations nos services elles ne
peuvent pas concurrencer des entreprises
étrangères qui cassent les prix avec des
produits non réutilisables jetables de
mauvaise qualité et fabriqués dans des
disques dans des conditions discutables
en Ariège les exemples ne manquent pas
biotech tissage Qatar sage ces
entreprises et d'autres nous offrent une
réelle capacité de développement
industriel de création d'emplois dans un
département qui en manque cruellement
monsieur le ministre pour ces
entreprises leurs salariés dans quelle
mesure l'État peut-il soutenir nos
industries dans cet objectif de
souveraineté industrielle je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
en charge de l'Industrie merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs députés
monsieur le député Laurent Pagny foot
merci pour votre question qui nous
permettra que la politique industrielle
de ce gouvernement de cette majorité
vis-à-ventoux à accélérer la radio de la
France qui a été entamée depuis
maintenant un quinquennat et quelques
mois vous l'avez dit le secteur du
textile fait partie des victimes des 50
dernières années qui s'est
progressivement vues hors de France pour
aller produire ailleurs des produits
pourtant que nous que nous pouvons que
nous sachions que nous savions par nos
produire vous l'avez dit la crise
sanitaire a été l'occasion pour un
certain nombre de ces entreprises de
relocaliser de reproduire en France les
régions étaient au rendez-vous je me
permets de vous rappeler aussi que
l'État l'a été également la fois par la
commande publique mais aussi par des
aides directes dont un certain nombre
d'entreprises de votre département ont
bénéficié dans le cadre de France
relance notamment nous devons aller plus
loin et vous le savez avec Bruno la
maire pardon nous travaillons à un
projet de loi qui vise à accélérer la
réindustrialisation en du fait que le
verdissement la transition écologique
doit être une opportunité pour nos
industries nous devons rapatrier des
objets du quotidien notamment dans
textile des t-shirts des pulls des
bonnets et autres nous devons rapatrier
des objets du quotidien des vélos des
voitures évidemment notamment des
véhicules électriques mais nous devons
aussi utiliser mieux que par le passé
tous les leviers notamment vous l'avez
dit celui de la commande publique pour
accompagner la relocalisation de nos
industries nous y travaillons dans le
cadre de ce projet de loi industriel
avec Bruno Le Maire la bonne nouvelle
c'est pour la première fois depuis
longtemps la Commission européenne elle
aussi semble reconnaître que les les
critères environnementaux d'une part
notre capacité à assurer la sécurité des
approvisionnements d'autre part
notamment pour des objets dont vous avez
pensionné qui concernent la santé des
européens ils sont prêts les intégrer
dans le code des marchés publics nous
sommes également prêts à le faire je
vous engage à continuer à accompagner le
gouvernement si je peux me permettre
cette petite pique plutôt que de voter
sa censure de manière à ce que nous
puissions continuer à l'industrialiser
ce pays merci monsieur le député je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Bruno Fuchs pour le
groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quotidienne en 1998 il y avait 36% des
textes qui étaient écrits à la
Commission européenne en français
aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus que deux
pour cent 36 2% dans les terres
scientifiques médicales seules
publications le son en langue française
quel signal envoie-t-on un étudiant en
médecine camerounais cambodgien ou
roumain quel message veut-on faire
passer lorsqu'on utilise officiellement
des appellations comme business France
tchuss France digital africain madame la
ministre la Francophonie est à la
croisée des chemins à cet égard sachez
que l'Assemblée parlementaire de la
Francophonie et ses 91 membres autour
d'un président canadien et d'invice
président gabonais jouera tout son rôle
madame la ministre vous l'avez compris
il faut agir vite quelle politique en
tenez-vous menée pour réinventer un
modèle qui susciterait adhésion et
espoir pour nos populations
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame christoulaz à
carreaux poules secrétaire d'État chargé
du développement de la Francophonie et
des partenariats internationaux merci
madame la Présidente
comme vous avez dit à cette semaine de
la francophonie nous célébrons la langue
française
cette langue tellement dynamique qu'il
est parlé sur les cinq continents ne
déplaise de clinistes mais notre langue
n'est pas recul avec 321 millions de
locuteurs elle reste aujourd'hui la
cinquième langue la plus parlée est la
deuxième langue étrangère la pluie a
pris au monde
partout les Français et synonymes des
changements et commerciaux des créations
et de diversités culturelles et
d'opportunités d'opportunités d'emploi
et de formation
sur la portion du président de la
République
nous agissons avec Madame la Ministre
Catherine colonne pour renforcer la
place de la langue française
nous le faisons ça à soutenant les
systèmes éducatif de nos partenaires
dans l'espace numérique dans les
milliers des affaires des entreprises et
des lajestitutionnes internationales
des rendez-vous très importants
prolongeront cet engagement dans les
prochaines mois avec l'ouverture à l'été
de la Cité internationale de la langue
française à Villers-Cotterêts ce sera un
lieu magnifique de création
d'apprentissage et d'innovation et comme
vous avez très bien dit nous travaillons
pour les 19e Sommet de la Francophonie
qui leur a lieu chez nous en France en
2024 je vous remercie je vous remercie
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Rodrigo Arenas pour le groupe
la France insoumise
dis-moi cela fait 10 mois que votre
gouvernement est à l'oeuvre et qu'il
méprise qu'il maltraite les Françaises
et les Français personne n'était parié
même pas nos professeurs qui ont
pourtant entre leurs mains l'avenir de
la France c'est-à-dire nos enfants
hier vous leur aviez promis des hausses
de salaire tellement minime que nos
enseignants resteront toujours moins
bien payés que la moyenne de leurs
collègues européens d'ailleurs c'est
tout Moon que vous appelez le pacte
enseignant il vient d'être rejeté par
l'ensemble des représentations des
professeurs
aujourd'hui vous fermez leur classe
aggravant la dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail et demain est-ce
que vous les obligerez à travailler
davantage avant de pouvoir profiter de
leur retraite quel maltraitance vous
justifiez tout cela on nous expliquant
que le pays n'a pas les moyens qu'il
faut faire des économies c'est
d'ailleurs la seule raison que vous avez
trouvé pour nous imposer votre réforme
de retraite injuste et injustifié
mais
pour les écoles privées les moyens vous
les avez trouvés
car dans ces écoles que vous connaissez
bien puisqu'il est de notoriété publique
que vous y scolarisez vos enfants ce
sont nos impôts qui financent les
salaires de leurs enseignants ce sont
nos impôts qui leur permettent d'avoir
plus d'heures d'enseignement pour leur
lycéens et c'est avec nos impôts qu'ils
contourne allègrement la mixité sociale
et la mixité scolaire alors je vous le
demande monsieur le ministre puisque
vous n'avez qu'une vision comptable du
monde quand allez-vous cesser de
privilégier l'école privée au détriment
de l'école publique quand allez-vous
enfin investir dans notre école publique
100% laïque la seule à garantir
l'accueil universel tous les enfants
quand allez-vous enfin faire le choix de
l'intérêt général car pour un euro que
vous donnez à l'école privée c'est un
euro que vous retirez à l'école publique
qui a besoin d'enseignants d'infirmières
scolaires de médecins scolaires pour
favoriser contre la lutte contre le
harcèlement et compter pour l'inclusion
c'est bon merci
la parole est à Monsieur Papa ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Arenas vous parlez de
maltraitance je veux bien que ces
temps-ci le langage soit fleuri mais il
dépasse les bornes le budget du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
augmente de 6 et demi pour cent plus 3,6
milliards d'euros cette année quel
maltraitance
permettez-moi de vous dire les
informations que vous fournissez sont
mal étayé je peux même dire que vous
vous moquez du monde par votre
intervention plus 3,6 milliards d'euros
nous allons augmenter et vous sembler
l'ignorer nous allons augmenter les
enseignants de deux manières d'une part
par le socle le socle c'est 1,9
milliards d'euros pour tous les
enseignants depuis Léonie titules les
néo titulaires jusqu'à ceux qui sont en
fin de carrière et nous aurons dans
quelques jours l'occasion
avec les organisations syndicales avec
qui nous sommes en
concertation nous aurons l'occasion de
préciser cette augmentation socle elle
sera valable pour tout le monde et puis
il y a l'augmentation pacte qui sera en
effet lié à de nouvelles missions dont
nous avons besoin pour améliorer les
services de l'école en particulier pour
faire face à la question des 15 millions
d'heures annuels qui sont perdus faute
de remplacement nous aurons aussi la
possibilité de développer les sixième
tremplins grâce à des enseignements de
français et de mathématiques qui seront
assurés par les professeurs des écoles
alors plutôt que de vous lancer dans des
propos démagogiques qui n'ont aucun sens
regardez les chiffres monsieur le député
soyez sérieux et faites votre travail
c'est-à-dire regarder les données plutôt
que de faire des moulinets qui n'ont
aucune signification je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre allez-y mon cher
collègues c'est vous qui ne l'avez pas
vous direz ça à tous les parents et tous
les enfants qui seront dans les classes
surchargées dans toutes les capitales de
France et dans toutes les villes que
nous avons vous direz ça
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas dragon
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances c'est de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique hier matin je
suis allé rencontrer la direction et les
ouvriers salariés de Rinaldi structal
leader de la façade haute technologie en
aluminium basé à Pinon près de Laon dans
mon département de l'Aisne après avoir
souffert de la crise covid puis de la
crise énergétique et en même temps de la
hausse des matières premières c'est 80
salariés qui voient aujourd'hui leur
usine menacée de fermeture monsieur le
ministre cette entreprise est un fleuron
de notre industrie et nous leur devons
entre autres les façades du bâtiment
dans lequel vous-même vous travaillez je
peux aussi citer la pyramide du Louvre
le musée du quai Branly l'Opéra Bastille
ou encore la rénovation actuelle de la
tour Pleyel transformée demain en hôtel
pour les JO de Paris 2024 monsieur le
ministre allez-vous leur dire que leur
savoir-faire peut demain tomber dans
l'oubli que mon département déjà
fortement touché par les crises et le
chômage et la perte d'habitants
pas encore souffrir d'une unité de
production qui disparaît alors que
l'entreprise fonctionne exporte à
l'étranger et à même pour projet
d'embaucher les salariés sont motivés
ils ont sacrifié leur congés leur vie de
famille pour bosser plus votre quoiqu'il
en coûte n'est peut-être plus
d'actualité mais il faut sauver cette
entreprise parce que le carnet de
commandes courtes déjà jusqu'à l'année
prochaine monsieur le ministre la
souveraineté industrielle que vous
défendez doit être bien plus que des
mots ou un simple concept elle doit se
concrétiser en acte fort qu'avez-vous
l'intention de faire pour toutes ces PME
souvent inconnues du grand public mais
au savoir-faire incomparable je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député dragon
je vais déjà commencer par répondre très
simplement en lieu et place de Bruno Le
Maire je suggère si vous l'acceptez que
nous échangions très précisément sur la
situation de l'entreprise que vous
mentionnez et bien entendu des 85
salariés que vous mentionnez vous avez
mentionné monsieur le député dragon le
quoi qu'il en coûte effectivement nous
sommes nous avons dépassé le quoi qu'il
en coûte pour des raisons qui semblent
évidentes mais quoi qu'il advienne nous
sommes au côté des salariés des PME des
PMI des entreprises de taille
intermédiaires qui peuvent connaître des
difficultés en ce moment et nous savons
qu'il y en a un certain nombre donc déjà
hors de toute polémique de façon très
froide je suggère si vous l'acceptez que
nous parlions de la situation
éventuellement avec le ministre de
l'Industrie qui est aussi présent pour
voir si nous pouvons prendre attache des
dirigeants mais surtout de la situation
de l'entreprise sur le reste je n'ai pas
très envie de polémiquer inutilement
votre question est très claire à nous
trouver des réponses il faut qu'on
prenne la mesure de la situation de
cette entreprise pour ce qui est d'être
aux côtés des salariés pour ce qui est
d'être côté des entreprises
pour lutter contre l'inflation qu'elle
soit d'ailleurs celle que vivent nos
ménages comme l'inflation des matières
premières et des intrants que vivent nos
PME nous sommes à leurs côtés je
rappelle juste deux chiffres qui me
semblent importants juste sur l'année
2023 rien que le bouclier est tarifaire
pour les salariés c'est 46 milliards
d'euros de présence de l'État 46
milliards d'euros c'est l'équivalent
d'une guerre pour mener l'inflation
c'est 10 porte-avions c'est le budget du
ministère de la Défense nous sommes aux
côtés des salariés nous sommes aux côtés
des entreprises 12 milliards d'euros
sont en ce moment en train d'arriver sur
les factures d'énergie pour accompagner
nos entreprises il y a d'autres sujets
et d'autres problèmes prenons-en prenons
quelques minutes pour en parler ensemble
je vous garantis qu'on va regarder ça
très précisément je vous remercie je
vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur dragon merci madame la ministre
pour cette bonne foi je vous invite même
venir à venir dans cette entreprise avec
moi parce que franchement les larmes qui
coulent sur les joues des salariés n'est
plus supportables pour personne je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Jean -Louis Thieriot pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Seine-et-Marne
la décision n'a fait l'objet d'aucune
concertation sérieuse avec les habitants
de crise noire qui l'ont vécu comme un
véritable bras d'honneur aux communes
rurales
de la visite de vos services à crise
noire la semaine dernière la pige
l'agence publique pour l'immobilier de
la Justice a présenté les décisions
comme arrêter et a toujours refusé de
faire une étude comparative d'autres
solutions étaient possibles je pense en
particulier à la friche industrielle du
Clos Saint-Louis dans la ville de
Dammarie-les-Lys alors monsieur le garde
des sceaux ma question est très simple
il y a-t-il une cohérence entre la
politique de la justice et la politique
de l'environnement monsieur le garde des
sceaux renoncer aussi deux crises noires
il n'est pas trop tard pour conjuguer
justice et écologique et pour en faire
un exemple de l'action de l'État
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le député Thériault
je reconnais que c'était assez singulier
que ce soit moi qui vous réponde à une
question qui est adressée aux garde des
sceaux que j'excuse puisque vous avez vu
qu'il pouvait pas être parmi nous mais
comme vous posez la question de la
compatibilité éventuelle de la lutte
contre l'artificialisation et la
construction de prison il me revient d'y
répondre
d'abord vous l'avez dit ça s'inscrit
dans un projet qui est le un projet de
construction de 15000 places de prison
présenté le 20 avril 2021 et qui fait
face à la fois au constat de la
surpopulation carcérale et un constat
fait ici que c'est pas le nombre de
prison qui doivent déterminer ensuite
les décisions des juges mais c'est bien
l'état de la délinquance et la volonté
de la société qui doit ensuite conduire
à avoir des réponses pénales qui soient
approprié et je ne pense pas que vous
compteziez le nombre de places de prison
puisque c'est moins que ce que François
Fillon avec 16000 et que Valérie
Pécresse avec 20000 avait proposé c'est
bien la question de la localisation dès
le mois d'avril 2021 le site de crise
Noah a été
identifié vous avez posé une question
écrite au mois d'octobre et dans la
continuité la réponse qui vous a été
faite c'est que ce site qui est situé
sur un terrain agricole a d'abord été
choisi par la Communauté de Communes et
il a été sur une zone d'aménagement
concerté que celle de Chris Noah fujus
qui était de toute façon prévu pour une
trajectoire d'artificialisation et qui
dans les documents d'Urban locaux
n'avait plus vocation à avoir cette
origine agricole en parallèle la semaine
dernière le gouvernement conformément
aux engagements qu'il a pris devant la
MF et à la manière dont la première mise
c'est exprimé sur le sujet à déposer un
amendement dans le cadre de l'examen de
la PPL sénatoriale pour faire en sorte
d'amodies d'amender le dispositif de 0
artificialisation net pour préciser que
les grands projets d'envergure nationale
ne devait pas faire l'objet d'une
comptabilité par commune mais faire
l'objet d'un comté à part que ce soit
pour les sujets qui relèvent de la
souveraineté de la décarbonation ou du
régalien et donc de ce point de vue ces
deux trajectoires ne sont pas
incompatibles compte tenues à la fois de
cet amendement et du texte qui nous sera
soumis bientôt merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à madame Béatrice Piron
pour le COP Renaissance
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées de France
Monsieur le Ministre vendredi 17 mars
2023 a eu lieu la première journée
nationale des aides à domicile cette
journée a été l'occasion de rappeler le
rôle essentiel de ses professionnels
maillon crucial de la vie quotidienne
des personnes en perte d'autonomie
qu'elles soient en situation de handicap
malade ou âgée les aides à domicile
accompagnent leur quotidien et leur
permettre notamment de rester dans leur
propre foyer afin de vieillir à domicile
choix partager par plus de 85% des
Français je profite également de cette
occasion pour remercier les conseils
départementaux ainsi que les
organisations qui ont célébré cette
première journée nationale avec des
aides à domicile nombreuses ce jour-là
avant d'être élu j'ai travaillé dans le
secteur de l'aide à domicile auprès des
personnes âgées et je reste en contact
régulier avec des professionnels de bon
département
vendredi il me confie encore que leur
secteur d'activité est toujours plus
attention toujours plus en difficulté au
point de craindre la fermeture de
quelques organisations il y a donc une
nécessité constante de revaloriser ce
métier et de les soutenir eux qui se
sont en mobilisés en première ligne
pendant la pandémie covid eux qui
prennent soin de nos aînés prochainement
une proposition de loi portant en mesure
pour bâtir la société du Bien vieillir
en France va être débattue au sein de
notre hémicycle parmi ces objectifs
plusieurs mesures concernent
l'amélioration et l'accompagnement de
ces professionnels d'aide à domicile
pouvez-vous nous préciser monsieur le
ministre les prochaines mesures que vous
envisagez de mettre en place afin de
valoriser cette profession essentielle
et plus largement faciliter le quotidien
de nos aînés et de ses professionnels
merci je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma
chère collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe combe ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députés
Béatrice Piron je vous remercie pour
votre question qui me donne
l'opportunité de revenir sur la première
journée des aides à domicile et cette
belle réussite j'ai eu plaisir à
l'organiser avec l'ensemble du secteur
avec les professionnels pour les
remercier pour leur engagement pour les
remercier aussi et mettre en valeur leur
place la place essentielle qui est la
leur dans notre société dans notre
solidarité nationale nous le savons tous
pour concrétiser le virage domiciliaire
et puis pour faire du souhait
majoritaire des Français de rester à
domicile une réalité nous avons besoin
de recruter des aides à domicile et pour
cela nous deux nous leur devons une
totale reconnaissance nous le devons à
Suzanne à Nadia à toutes celles et ceux
qui me disent aimer exercer leur métier
un métier dont toutes les personnes
âgées ou en situation de handicap qui
sont accompagnées connaissent
l'importance depuis sanitaire nous avons
agi on a multiplié les actions de
soutien avec des revalorisations
salariales sans précédent ou encore en
renforçant les structures les structures
via la mise en place d'un tarif plancher
et d'une dotation qualité la situation
n'est bien sûr pas parfaite et nous
allons continuer à agir que ce soit via
le CNR bien vieillir que ce soit via la
proposition de loi que vous avez
mentionné ou via le plan métier que nous
travaillons avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement à la demande de la première
ministre on prendra les mesures
nécessaires pour continuer à revaloriser
ces métiers je parle de la
revalorisation salariale mais aussi des
parcours de la formation de
l'organisation du travail parce que ce
sont des métiers aussi on doit organiser
l'équilibre entre la vie personnelle et
la vie professionnelle où on travaillera
également il y a des propositions à ce
sens dans la proposition de loi sur la
question de la mobilité de ces
professionnels cette politique je la
porte sur l'ensemble de mon champ auprès
de l'ensemble des professionnels et j'en
profite pour rappeler qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la journée internationale du
travail social et ça me permet de rendre
hommage à l'ensemble de ces travailleurs
qui sont si utiles à notre nature je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au Gouvernement la
séance est terminée la séance est
suspendue pour une durée de 15 minutes